from the worldwide leader in sports so
much going on in association so we
decided to call him up hi doing Brian
hey rich how does the trade deadline
being moved affected things do you think
good question um it's so fresh nobody
really knows I mean it's a pretty big
move it's a two-week move and it means
it's going to hit more in midseason than
it would have before where it's a little
bit later in the year my initial
reaction would be that typically we see
certain teams hit the eject button at
some point in midseason decide they're
sellers I you know baseball teams are
going through that right now for example
and I would guess that if it happens
earlier in the year you may have fewer
sellers that there are there be there
are more games left there are more teams
that are convinced that they can still
make the playoffs so as a initial
reaction my guess is that might stifle a
little bit of action but one of the
things that we've seen over the last
couple of years is there's sort of two
waves of trades one wave of trade starts
happening in December for various
reasons primarily because of free agents
can be traded starting December 15th and
then there's another second wave of
trades that have been around the
deadline in February my guess is that
that would collapse
the trade season and make it a little
bit more more you know stuff together so
in that way it may create more of a
trade season even if there may be less
deals total Brian when Horst in the
Honda inside a report I did not hear
anything
essentially codified to try and
eliminate star players being rested on
the road
certainly in cities that only get one
shot at a star player coming into their
building what was discussed based your
knowledge and the Board of Governors
about all that Brian no no there was so
the season opening will be July I will
be October 17th which is about 12 days
earlier than it was last year and so
those extra 12 days will be built into
the schedule to allow more rest if you
were back-to-back so in
theory there's going to be less of a
reason to rest players because there's
going to be you know ten or so extra
days built into the season now the thing
about it is rich this has got to be a
collaborative effort this can't just be
the league altering the schedule a
little bit there's also got to be a
recognition from the players and teams
that there's a business aspect to this
and you know I am certainly a believer
in player health and the development of
sports science but I'm also a pragmatist
and you have to realize that you have to
take care of your customers when you
begin disrespecting your customers you
possess you put yourself in position to
have business troubles and so what I
really think the best you know the best
rule of advice would be to the NBA teams
is don't disrespect your customers when
you consider about resting a player
consider the business factors they're in
there don't let the business factors
lead but consider them and I think
that's a mandate that comes from
ownership and I think that's where Adam
silver is trying to make this clean now
whether or not there's going to be
cooperation on this or not I think
that's what we're going to determine in
this next season so it's basically like
we can't tell you what to do but what
we're going to do is build in an extra
week and a half into the season and
those ten days should supplant the 10
days that the Cavs say rested LeBron
James and even though they did that we
still heard about how LeBron was
somewhat out of gas in a playoffs that
he played a remarkable small amount of
games before getting to the finals where
he had to carry too much of a load you
see where I'm going with this whole
thing Brian and the other thing is with
sports science it's not like you can
look at the schedule in October and say
hey our player is going to be tired to
stay in February that's the whole point
they track these players and the idea is
when they get a what we when the signals
go off with the with the analytics that
they analyze to indicate the players
running down that's when they give them
a day off and whether that happens on a
home game against a nobody opponent or
it happens on a road game at national
television game sometime
you can't control it so obviously this
is still going to be an issue however
what the league is saying is meet us
halfway here you you complained about
having back to back so you so when you
took off the Saturday night games okay
we're going to make sure that you don't
play on a Saturday night or Sunday
afternoon where you have it to play the
day before so meet us in between and if
you have a choice between taking that
Saturday night game off or taking the
following Monday game off at home
against the worst team in the league how
about you take Monday off instead that's
what they're asking them to do to come
to the middle I can't predict how it's
going to happen but the league is taking
action here and so we'll see whether the
players and coaches you know come to the
middle in that regard as well ESPN's
Brian windhorse joining me here in the
Honda inside a report what's the latest
between the Rockets and the Knicks for
Carmelo what's going on here yeah this
is a this is a challenge and as of
yesterday I really don't think they had
traction on this I know that there were
reports out there that that wasn't true
that they did I from what I'm being told
there's no traction there's a desire the
Rockets want to trade for Carmelo and
that's interesting to me because Carmelo
and Mike D'Antoni were not friends when
he was head coach to the next and Melo
wants to go to Houston which is relevant
here because he has a no-trade clause
and not only is it granting permission
but he's got an eight million dollar
bonus that he gets if he's traded rich
and that makes it very hard to trade him
he has the opportunity to waive that all
or part of it rich of Chris Paul did
this in his trade to Houston he waived
almost all of it so the trade would go
through so Melo having interest in going
to Houston is important but there's not
a natural trade there there's certain
players the Rockets don't want to give
up in certain players that they that the
Knicks don't want to swallow and I think
we could be in for a stalemate I do
think when historically when we see two
teams that are very motivated to make a
trade typically we see that trade
eventually happen but neither side has
any motive to Ches and the discussions
right now we're in July so I would just
keep an eye on it but I don't think it's
a boiling situation right now
Paul George introduced in Oklahoma City
yesterday Brian Wynn worst what of his
what at what needs to happen for him to
stay and sign long term they have a shot
here he kind of gave a little bit of a
road map where he referenced you know if
we could get the conference finals or
finals obviously if you got to the
finals that means you somehow got
through or around the warrior yeah but
he wasn't binding and you know I think
if you look at the way he approached his
last season in Indiana I don't see why
he would be any different and that is he
makes very positive comments about the
team he's on but absolutely nothing that
you could use against him later he will
leave every sentence he states on the
record about it will leave an out
because that is the playbook and I don't
expect that to change and to me what's
very interesting here is a russell
westbrook hasn't signed that contract
extension and frankly rich he doesn't
have a lot of motives to do so he's in a
different situation than Steph Curry and
James Harden were in she doesn't have a
monetary advantage for signing the
extension because he's a little a little
bit more experienced level than those
other guys the Thunder can't give him
any more money that he could get anyway
if he waited a year but he has an option
built into a contract for 30 million
next year so he's got an insurance
policy even if he gets hurt or something
he's protected so if I were his agent
I would probably advise him not to sign
that contract just to see how things go
and that means that it's going to be an
incredible all-in season for the Thunder
is all-in as any team I've I've seen in
recent memory because they have a team
that has a chance to seriously compete
but they also have a team that they have
no control over probably after this
season and neither Paul nor nor Russ
Westbrook is holding the pen ready to
sign right now and of course we all know
Paul George has made it known that he'd
like to go to the Los Angeles Lakers who
have Lonzo ball front and center in Las
Vegas right now Brandon Ingram also
supposedly one of another young players
that could attract Paul George even more
and then last night sitting watching the
game
was LeBron James wearing purple and
everybody around here I mean how much
there was he wearing there I thought it
was just a regular tie-dye t-shirt no I
mean there was a lot of Prayer it was
purplish yeah I think was predominantly
purple purple is young so how much there
is there in the conversation that he is
there in Las Vegas to kick the tires on
either the Lakers or the Sixers he was
sitting in front of last night which
here's the thing whether LeBron had come
to that game or not he's still going to
be a free agent next year and it's still
going to be incumbent on the Cavs to be
attractive for him to stay and part of
it is going to be the east/west
imbalance that may plays the Cavs favor
but LeBron doesn't have to LeBron has a
wonderful situation that if you're at
the top of your field you no matter what
field you're in if you're if you're one
of the top neurosurgeons in the country
you can probably go to any Hospital you
want if you declare yourself a free
agent every hospital in the country is
ready to take you that's a situation
LeBron is in he unlike teams who have to
prepare for years in advance for free
agency LeBron can keep his options open
because he's so damn good so he's in a
position where it doesn't matter what
game he goes to in in July he knows the
options are going to be there the
following July that's just the way it's
going to be and that's not going to
change in in December it's not going to
change in April [ __ ] a change in June
it really just matters where he is in
July and I know as part of my job I'm
going to get asked about this for the
next 11 months oh yeah and my answer is
going to be the same every time
it doesn't matter what LeBron feels like
on that day all that matters is what he
feels like on July 1st so what was he
doing it was he is he is he taking in
the Backstreet Boys show - I mean what's
he doing in office to do this must be
nice he wore a full Lakers get up
yesterday my thinking on this would not
not paint he has before he does Richmond
this I I'm sorry if I've used this
before what are you having for dinner on
June 30th 2018 I have no earthly idea
Brian but you know that if somebody has
a job and just somebody who lives in a
civilized society but if you
want salmon you can have it if you want
steak you can have it if you want
chicken you can have you know why would
you worry about it you're not worried
about it today but if I had nothing
better to do I would go to two
restaurants that serve steak and salmon
to just check it out to know whether
when that day comes what go what latter
on to go to because you can order the
finest a candle in the country because
you have the means to do some well it
was like I did that's okay it's not
going to matter seriously others I'm
gonna be very clear if the cabs went 82
I know this last regular season and they
went 16 and OH in the playoffs and in
the finals LeBron went a hundred and
fifty in 150 from the field and and
french-kiss Dan Gilbert as they won the
second I answer would exactly be the
same today and that is that LeBron will
get to free-agency next year look at the
lay of the land and decide on his best
option he he doesn't have anything
decided because he has the luxury of not
having to decide now that's what I got
just a reality which is that that he
living that's what I call an insider
report right there
last one for you before I let you go did
Durant know about Peyton Manning's joke
great question Mike I always assumed I
always assumed conspiracy but I don't
have the insider
sasb information too much because I
always assume that that things are
worked out I mean certainly that that
Cody what's the catcher's name from the
Cubs I'm not a baseball guy David is
Ross de Vaca he's my coworker I'm sorry
certainly that was scripted out my guess
is there was a lot of scripting that
went into that show Brian thanks for the
call well chat soon okay
you got it that's Brian win or stand the
Honda auditor insider report the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show app
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show